[Music]
joining me today is a civil rights and
constitutional lawyer with the Freedom
From Religion Foundation and a man who
according to his Twitter bio believes
that life is too good to waste on bad
ideas Andrew Seidel welcome to the Rubin
report thank you for having me on I'm
very excited to be here
well I'm excited to have you we have
we've met once in real life not on
camera as as citizens out there in the
world we had a couple of drinks and and
then we went to a recent rally and then
we went to the reason rally and I spoke
at the reason rally and we it was a
weekend full of free thinking it was it
was oh it was a lovely time I really I
really enjoyed it in the nation's
capital no less right in front of the
Lincoln Memorial yeah it was hot as hell
that weekend I don't know how those
people bunch of atheists get together
you know and God was not kind when it
came to the the humidity that line
though I want to get it right just right
life is too good to waste on bad ideas
that is in your Twitter bio and it's on
your website and I just love it it's
simple and pleasant and it's right thank
you
right why are we so bad at this that we
waste so much time on bad ideas because
we're irrational we're emotional beings
we would love to be these these fully
rational creatures that way the evidence
perfectly and don't have a problem
making decisions on weighing that
evidence but we don't do that we think
we do it at times but we're actually
really really bad at it and one of the
things that I really tried to do is to
examine the ideas that I hold in the
beliefs that I hold and make sure
they're supported by evidence it's one
of the reasons I'm I'm not religious
it's one of the reasons I help people
who aren't religious and it's one of the
reasons that I chose that kind of as my
personal personal motto yeah
when did you kind of wake up to all of
this I mean I would I was never I was
never really religious
I didn't start getting getting active in
atheism and secularism until I started
learning about the First Amendment
really in law school I actually I was
reading The God Delusion
in Iceland travelling around Iceland
after I had stuck
brought into Amsterdam I was doing
international law in Amsterdam studying
an am stirring in six weeks we went to
the Hague and everything I have I have
decent grades to show for did you make
it to the red-light district you can
just not according we I walked through
just about every day on the way to class
and I was awakened to this kind of whole
world of how religion is infusing itself
in the law and its religion is so
irrational and so non evidence-based and
it was guiding so much of the decisions
that were that were governing our
everyday lives and I was learning about
this as I was learning about
constitutional law and learning about
the First Amendment and just sort of the
coincidence of those two things just
kind of changed my career you know I
originally went to law school to be an
environmental lawyer I was going to save
the world yeah and now I am I'm just
doing it a different way in a slightly
different way all right so let's talk
about the First Amendment because
everyone watching this knows I like to
think of myself as some sort of free
speech warrior I'm a free speech
absolutist that you cannot call for
direct violence that would be a criminal
offense and I do believe in in libel
laws and maybe we can get into that I'm
not sure what your stance is on that but
the 40 you make of the general well
first of what is the First Amendment for
people that don't know people get very
confused about what just for the idea of
free speech short verse the First
Amendment let's just do 100 first so I
mean the First Amendment is the first
amendment to the Constitution that
Congress passed I was proposed in 1789
ratified in 1791 it says that Congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof or abridging
the freedom of speech or of the press or
of the right of the people to peaceably
assemble and petition their government
for a redress of grievances so that's
actually not just one right that's six
different rights
that's a secular government the free
exercise of religion the freedom of
speech press assembly and petition yeah
it's beautiful right like it's all in
there it is it is it's the gold standard
of freedom and it's it's in a I mean
it's it's amazingly condensed to and
it's if you had to sum it up really
really what it does what all those six
rights do is they protect the freedom of
thought that's what that's what they're
all meant to do all the rights in there
are to assert all
raids rights we have actually are
limited to a certain extent with the
exception of the freedom of freedom of
thought
so you mentioned freedom of speech he
mentioned libel laws and that you can't
call for a direct violence and incite
violence those are limits on your
freedom of speech the limit there are
limits on just about every other rights
you have except the freedom of thought
and that's really what we are seeking to
protect that's what the First Amendment
protects is is the own the one absolute
right that we have and it it's a
beautiful thing yeah it is a beautiful
thing do you think people get confused
when they talk about free speech versus
the First Amendment yes all the time I
see this you know that somebody will say
something people will get outraged by it
or someone will lose their job at a
private company I'm not for people
generally speaking I'm not for public
being fired for sharing their thoughts
obviously but I also believe in the
right of a private company to do what
they want to do I don't want the
government telling them what they want
to do etc etc so people get this all
kind of cross stuff they absolutely do I
mean the firt the first word of the
First Amendment is Congress
yeah and that's been interpreted to
apply to the entire government right so
so it means that the government can't
infringe on your free speech it means
that the government can't tell you how
to worship or endorse a particular
religion or prohibit your ability to
assemble that's what the First Amendment
does free speech is more general it's
the ethos that underlies it it's it's we
shouldn't a company shouldn't want to
fire somebody just for speaking their
mind that's that's kind of free speech
and people definitely get them conflated
and I've gotten into several exciting
Twitter battles over this yeah I don't
know fully what your political beliefs
are but are you with me on that general
concept that although you wouldn't like
it if a company fired someone over
something maybe that they to a joke they
tweeted or that kind of thing but you
would allow the company to make their
decision sure I mean and certainly it's
certainly not a constitutional right
that the person has right unless they
are working for the government
yeah and even then you know in certain
limited circumstances so another place
that this gets confused a lot is in my
work so we handle at the Freedom From
Religion Foundation 5,000 state church
complaints every year and half of those
are in public schools
one of the things that we get all the
time is teachers who are imposing their
religion on their students and we often
hear even from opposing counsel well
with the teachers have a free speech
right and a right to their religious
freedom so they're allowed to impose
their religion on students and that's
just that's not true yeah they are they
are for all intents and purposes the
government the teachers are employed by
the government they are the government
they don't get to exercise their free
speech or freedom of religion in a way
that imposes on other people's children
yeah so to be clear you're making an
obvious distinction between a public
school in a private school right private
school they they can do what they want
sure what kind of case would that be
where teachers imposing something like
are they what generally like what is the
teacher doing saying well you know you
should be following the teachings of
Jesus yeah so I mean last week I got a
call from a mom down south and this is
fairly fairly typical case that we get
her third grade student her son's third
grade teacher was having all the kids
before they went down to lunch for the
day line up to go sanitize their hands
and before they did that they had to
save the Lord's Prayer and show me
that's I'm not a lawyer seems kind of
cut and dry
you would think so yeah except that we
get 2,500 complaints in the public
schools every single year yeah and
they're they're all relatively like this
so a lot of times it's teaching
creationism it's just it's teachers
taking this public position that they
have to and using it to promote their
personal religion it's an abuse of power
yeah and you'd think everybody would be
against that but we have a hard time
correcting these so when you get a call
like that in something that seems like a
very clear-cut case I think probably
well certainly for my audience but I
think 90% of I think thinking people
would realize that there's an issue with
that having students that could be of
any religion or not religious at all or
even if they're of the Catholic faith
and they're Christian you shouldn't have
to do that obviously what is your action
there do you guys first call the school
and say you shouldn't be doing this and
you know we're not trying to get into a
legal battle here or do you immediately
have to like send something I'll be like
you guys are in some legal trouble
well we always want to work with
school district rather than against that
especially public schools like I don't
want to be suing a public school and
taking money out of the public school
and time out of the public school
they're already burdened enough we want
them to be focusing on educating
students so our first step is always to
educate and oftentimes it's enough so in
in this case I wrote a letter and that's
usually the first step we do we just
rewrite a letter we explain this is what
the law says this is why what the
teachers doing is wrong and usually
that's enough to make the change but
sometimes it's not and in this case
actually the mom had already went down
to the principal's office and talked to
the principal and said you know what's
going on you can't be doing this and
then the principal didn't do anything so
we went straight to the superintendent
and pointed out the problems it's it's a
very frustrating situation when the law
is so clear mm-hmm and the the opponents
the government is so unwilling to uphold
it and it does happen and that's when we
start looking at okay now we're gonna
have to sue you and we we are certainly
willing to do that but again you know
our preference is to solve these things
with education yeah how often do you
find that people don't want to just
speak up about this so you're saying in
this case the the mother went to the
principal and it didn't get resolved and
then you guys had to take over but I
suspect that there are a lot of case
it's not just when it comes to religion
but all kinds of things that people's
rights are being infringed on and they
don't even they don't even take the
first step of trying to address it they
would then go the legal route that may
be ultimately okay for you guys but that
that that chill factor that's what I
talk a lot about here that people are
just afraid of speaking up for things
even when it is their right to do so
that's a huge issue in what I do it's it
happens in just about every case most of
the people who contact us have never
taken any steps on their own and they
are afraid too and that's actually one
of the functions that FFRF has is to
serve as a buffer between that person
and their school I mean these people
have to be in the school you know that
kids got to be in the school for another
nine years right and he's gonna have to
live with having protested that and it
could be very difficult for him so one
of the things that we try to do is to
protect the identity of these people
and historically it's incredibly
important because if you speak out
against religion in a small community
the backlash can be pretty severe yeah
you know there are there are cases where
we've actually seen mothers of
plaintiffs so when you actually have
taken this to court where the mother was
assaulted by a lunch lady after she was
dropping her kid off at school
physically assaulted her house was
firebombed later and that was in the 80s
and it was in Oklahoma but you know a
couple years ago in Rhode Island a young
girl named Jessica Ahlquist challenged a
prayer banner that was hanging in her
public school and she had to go to a
school with a police escort for a number
of years she was vilified on social
media
hundreds of death threats and her her
state representative her state
representative got on the radio and
called her an evil little thing being
manipulated by evil people you know just
before the show we were talking about
when some public figures are very kind
of proud proudly anti-gay LGBTQ rights
or maybe anti anti atheist that you can
set your washing yeah couple years later
just a couple months ago he was found to
have been embezzling from his campaigns
so the chill factor when it comes to
this stuff I see that as a bigger threat
to the idea of free speech than any
threat that I see directly to the First
Amendment at the moment at the moment at
least do you think that's fair to say
like I see us silencing ourselves now I
see that in just creeping into
everything right now the direct threat
from the government although there's
obviously cases like this you know
individual schools and things of that
nature is a problem I don't see that
sort of systemically
reaching out am I am I wrong on that
well I think one of the things that
people need to realize and this is
actually in a Supreme Court case that
the court does a great job of explaining
this the case on fighting words you know
when when does that free speech right
kind of start to get curtailed are these
actual fighting words in which case you
don't have a free speech right to say
them and what they what the court was
talking about is they say that the whole
point of free speech is to create
friction it's to invite
it's - its to get people arguing and to
make you uncomfortable that is that is
what it is designed to do because we
don't want complacency when complacency
is wrong so I think that the chilling of
speech is certainly a concern and it's a
concern that the courts have when
they're when they're analyzing this I
mean it's it's one of the things they
look at when does a law burden speech by
by chilling it and by having people and
that's actually the language that the
court uses by having them not just
having that law in place makes people
less likely to speak up for instance so
I think it's it's certainly a concern
and the this the self-censorship which
religion happens to be very good at yeah
is is definitely problematic yeah we're
gonna get two more really to get I am I
love it I talk about what are the other
direct threats from the government that
you see right now because I see a lot of
people will say well Trump is a direct
threat to the First Amendment now I see
he says things about reporters which
surely I haven't seen him silence a
reporter but I do think that also is a
chill effect because if a report you're
a reporter you don't want then
absolutely not fun if you're a reporter
and the President of the United States
is saying mean things about you like
that that that that is the same chill
effect but is there something else may
be related directly to the First
Amendment that's coming from the
government right now that the average
person isn't seeing or maybe that's what
I think I think there are actually some
some direct examples of what you're
talking about already I mean Trump is
calling on news organizations that are
that are friendly to him and keeping out
news organizations that are critical of
him yeah what is that new I mean I think
I think everybody's done that right I
mean Obama did that maybe it's a little
more odd and I think I think it's a
little more obvious and I think it's a
little more deliberate and I think I
think the bigger problem really for
Trump the bigger or the bigger problem
that I have with Trump is just his
complete ignorance of the Constitution
in general I don't think we've ever had
a president that has so little
understanding or respect for the way
government works and I don't think he
knows that there is a separation of
powers in the government I kept saying
during the election that if you want to
stop this guy somebody just has to ask
him flat out what are the three branches
of government and what are they supposed
to do like if you want to just really
get him in
in just a you know ninth grade social
studies that's what you should know kind
of moment that that would have done some
damage I mean I catalogued this a while
a while ago before before the election
also and there are a number of things he
said you know talked about the thee was
gonna protect all 27 articles at the
Constitution there aren't quite that
many you know I mean he he just is
genuinely ignorant and and that's scary
in a personality like his that is at
heart a bully and that sees any type of
compromise or forgiveness as weakness or
apology as weakness that that is a scary
combination so is there a piece of that
though that if we are governed the way
we're supposed to be with the proper
checks and balances and separation of
powers that no matter how crazy he went
it wouldn't matter if we were really
governed the way we were supposed to be
in that short full way that the founders
set up that if he went completely
bananas and did a lot of stuff that was
illegal and all that well actually there
are many processes in place to stop that
and I don't know that we're governed
that way anymore which is a problem but
well I mean I think that is that is the
test that we are going to see is is our
Constitution and is this form of
government strong enough to withstand a
totalitarian and at least a totalitarian
mindset and and so far it looks like it
is you know the Muslim travel ban travel
in 2.0 it looks like things are
functioning as they are supposed to
George Orwell wrote this great letter
before he had actually written in 1984
and in it he was talking about how the
UK how England and how America had never
been tested the way a lot of these other
countries had been tested with with
totalitarian regimes and I think we are
coming up to that point here I think I
think you know it's hard to say that he
is but I think he's definitely got that
mindset for sure
[Music]
you